担任）おはようございまーす
一同）おはざいま～す
担）はい
担）では本日のテストですが
担）テスト時間が50分となっています
担）教養問題のテストなんですけども
担）結構真剣に解かなきゃいけないというところと
担）時間の勝負というテストになっておりますので
担）なるべく多くの問題を解けるようにやっていって下さい
はじめ（どいつもこいつも舐めた顔しやがってっ！）
は（俺はこのクラスで）
（髪の毛の毛量（？）が多いからって皆からいじられている）
（最近それがヒートアップしてきて）
（だんだん悪化してきて）
（俺はとても教室に居づらいんだ！）
生徒）おい！　出て来いよ！　おい！
は）うぅ…うぅ…うぅ…（もう限界なんだ！）
うぅ…（くそぉぉぉぉ！！）
うぅぅ…（もう限界だ！俺はもう限界だ！）
（もう許さないぞお前達）
（どうなっても知らねぇからなっ！）
はぁ…（俺はお前たちに）
（拳で対抗するっ！！）
（今日のテストの為に俺は沢山の電気ビリビリペンを準備した）
（これは特別な改造がしてあり）
（ノックすると３０万ボルトの電流が流れ）
（感電してしまうっていうやつだ）
（ｱｯﾊﾊｧ!!）
（これを使ってクラス全員地獄に叩き落してやるよ！）
（ｱｯﾊｧ!!）
（全員分ちゃんと電流が流れないか）
（自分で全部テストした…）
いてぇぇ！（死ぬかと思ったZE☆）
はぁはぁ…（くそったれがァ！！）
（はぁ…まぁいいだろう）
（これであいつらに…）
（日頃の復讐が出来るわけだからなァ？）
ハッハッハハッハァ！！(ﾃﾞｽﾎﾞ)
（こいつらは今から全員電流流れること知らないんだぜぇ？）
（はぁヤベ、緊張してきたなぁアッハァ！（ﾃﾞｽﾎﾞ））
（バカみたいなツラしやがってよォ？）
（お前ら今からどうなるか分かってんだろうなぁ？）
（全員地獄行きだぜアッハッハッハァ！！）
（たまんねぇぜ）
（お前ら全員苦しむ顔が見られるなんてナァ？）
（ハッハッハッハ！！）
（お、テスト用紙とペンが配られるみたいだな）
（うちの学校はカンニング率が９５%だから）
（カンニングしないようにペンまで支給されるんだぜ）
（ハッ　だから簡単だったよ）
（いぃやぁ　楽しみだなァ　アッハァ！）
（おっとっと顔に出ちゃった）
（だから簡単だったよォ）
（このテストで配られるペンを全て）
（俺が用意した電気ビリビリペンにすり替えるだけで）
（お前ら全員テストの開始時にビリッビリだぜぇ！）
（あとはテスト開始を待つだけだ）
（ふぅ…緊張してきたぜ）
（俺のことをいじらないやつにも申し訳ないが）
（今回はクラス全員シビれてもらうぜぇ！）
（さぁ…地獄のショーの始まりだァ！！！）
担）では、今9時５３分になったので
担）ここから５０分間解きます
担）よーい…始めっ！
（ﾋﾞﾘﾋﾞﾘ…）
一同）うははははｗｗ
生徒）びっくりした
生徒）マジか！
は（あれ…？）
は（楽しそうなんだけど）
（このままじゃ仕返しにならねぇ…）
（ちくしょう…　担任！）
（テイク2だぁっ！！）
担）はぁい　じゃあテイク2行きまーす
担）では行きます
担）よーい…スタートっ！！
一同）うわぁぁぁぁ！！
は）えーっと　今日の動画は
は）え～以上ですｗ
一同）はははｗ
生徒）みじかっ
は）全部ペンビリビリペンだったらドッキリでした～！
は）お疲れ様でしたぁ！